Some stories are so profound, so unimaginable, that they stay with us forever. The Unthinkable is the latest podcast from Casefile Presents, hosted by two of Australia's leading voices in true crime, Vicky Petratus and Emily Webb. The series delves into tales of ordinary people who have faced extraordinary, often devastating events and emerged forever changed. From survivors of traumatic events to victims of relentless stalking and even those who've confronted some of Australia's most notorious criminals, The Unthinkable explores the depths of human resilience. The first two episodes feature the incredible story of Louisa Hope, a woman who survived
有些故事深刻得令人难以想象，以至于永远留在我们心中。《不可思议》（The Unthinkable）是 Casefile Presents 推出的最新播客，由澳大利亚两位顶尖的真实犯罪节目主持人维基·佩特拉图斯（Vicky Petratus）和艾米丽·韦伯（Emily Webb）主持。该系列深入探讨了普通人面对非同寻常、往往是毁灭性的事件，并从此彻底改变命运的故事。从创伤事件的幸存者到无情跟踪的受害者，甚至那些与澳大利亚最臭名昭著的罪犯对峙过的人，《不可思议》探索了人类韧性的深度。前两集讲述了路易莎·霍普（Louisa Hope）不可思议的故事，她是一位幸存者，
Sydney's Lindt Cafe siege in 2014. Both episodes will be available for free on Sunday November 10 wherever you get your podcasts, with episodes dropping weekly after that. Be sure to follow The Unthinkable so you don't miss an episode. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app,
2014年悉尼林特咖啡馆（Lindt Cafe）人质劫持事件。这两集将于11月10日星期日免费发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，之后每周更新一集。请务必关注《不可思议》，这样你就不会错过任何一集。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看你应用中本节目的节目说明，
or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium, and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. In 1999, married couple Ina and David Steinar launched Auction Bytes, an e-newsletter catering to those whose business was selling items online. The idea originated from the Steiners' shared interest in collecting and trading. Ina had amassed a large collection of books and, ever since childhood, her husband David had been a frequenter of yard sales, always on the
或访问我们的网站。本集最初是在 Casefile 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上作为付费订阅者的早期福利发布的。这些剧集旨在稍微缩短时长，使我们能够涵盖更广泛的案例。要提前收听这些无广告剧集，你可以在你喜欢的平台上支持 Casefile。1999年，已婚夫妇伊娜（Ina）和戴维·斯坦纳（David Steiner）创办了《拍卖字节》（Auction Bytes），这是一份面向在线销售商品的企业主的电子通讯。这个想法源于斯坦纳夫妇共同的收藏和交易兴趣。伊娜积累了大量的书籍，而她的丈夫戴维自童年起就是旧货市场的常客，总是留意着
lookout for antiques. The Steiners prided themselves on factually reporting the latest industry news and keeping readers up to date and informed on the inner workings of various online marketplaces. Ina did most of the writing, while David focused on the publication side of things. Although their newsletter began in the early days of internet commerce, it filled a niche and grew in popularity as online trading became an important tool for businesses worldwide. The Steiners eventually changed their publication's name to E-Commerce Bytes and by 2019, it was a valued and reputable resource for sellers on a number of online platforms,
古董。斯坦纳夫妇以如实报道最新的行业新闻，并让读者随时了解各种在线市场的内部运作而自豪。伊娜负责大部分写作，而戴维则专注于出版方面的工作。尽管他们的通讯始于互联网商业的早期，但它填补了一个空白，并随着在线交易成为全球企业的重要工具而日益普及。斯坦纳夫妇最终将他们的出版物更名为《电子商务字节》（E-Commerce Bytes），到2019年，它已成为多个在线平台卖家所珍视的权威资源，
including Craigslist, Etsy, Amazon and eBay. From her home in the town of Natick, Massachusetts, Ina published daily articles such as, What is Behind Amazon Prime Shipping Delays? and Craigslist Finally Launches a Mobile App, Worth the Wait. Ina also managed the Ecommerce Bytes social media accounts, which allowed her to directly engage with her small but passionate community. with her small but passionate community. On Thursday August 1 2019, the New York Times published an article detailing a lawsuit that US multinational e-commerce company eBay had recently filed against their direct competitor, Amazon. eBay was accusing Amazon of unlawfully poaching their sellers. Ina Steiner wrote about the dispute later
包括 Craigslist、亚马逊（Amazon）和 eBay。伊娜在马萨诸塞州纳蒂克（Natick）镇的家中每天发布文章，例如《亚马逊 Prime 配送延迟背后的原因是什么？》和《Craigslist 终于推出了移动应用，值得等待》。伊娜还管理着《电子商务字节》的社交媒体账户，这使她能够直接与她那规模虽小但充满热情的社区互动。2019年8月1日星期四，《纽约时报》发表了一篇文章，详细报道了美国跨国电子商务公司 eBay 最近对其直接竞争对手亚马逊提起的诉讼。eBay 指控亚马逊非法挖走他们的卖家。伊娜·斯坦纳后来写了关于这场纠纷的文章
that day in a post headlined, eBay lawsuit meant to curb seller exodus to Amazon. In it, she asserted, eBay's CEO Devin Wenig has been unable to stop a decline in market sales, but trying to dissuade sellers from turning to Amazon and trying to get Amazon to stop recruiting sellers may not be the best tactic. Days later on Wednesday August 7, the Ecommerce Bytes Twitter account received a private message from a user Ina didn't recognise. Their username was Tuilele and their profile picture was an image of a skull surrounded by darkness. They asked what Ina's problem was with eBay. Based on their Twitter bio, it appeared Tuilele was an eBay seller based in Samoa who was new to Twitter with no post history and no followers.
当天的一篇帖子标题为《eBay 诉讼旨在遏制卖家流向亚马逊》。她在文中断言：“eBay 首席执行官德文·温尼格（Devin Wenig）一直无法阻止市场销售额的下滑，但试图劝阻卖家不要转向亚马逊，并试图让亚马逊停止招募卖家，这可能不是最好的策略。”几天后的8月7日星期三，《电子商务字节》的 Twitter 账户收到了一条来自伊娜不认识的用户的私信。他们的用户名是 Tuilele，头像是一个被黑暗包围的骷髅图像。他们问伊娜对 eBay 有什么意见。根据他们的 Twitter 简介，Tuilele 似乎是一位居住在萨摩亚的 eBay 卖家，是 Twitter 的新用户，没有发帖记录，也没有粉丝。
Ina suspected they were a troll, an online provocateur who typically posted offensive content behind nameless accounts to arouse an emotional response in others. The best way to deal with the troll was not to respond to them at all, so Ina ignored Tuile's message. This only fuelled their anger. They sent Ina a stream of messages that read, Hello. What the fuck?
伊娜怀疑他们是网络喷子，即通常在匿名账户背后发布攻击性内容以激起他人情绪反应的网络挑衅者。对付喷子的最好方法就是根本不回应，所以伊娜忽略了 Tuilele 的信息。这反而助长了他们的愤怒。他们给伊娜发送了一连串的信息，写道：“你好。搞什么鬼？”
Are you there? I'm waiting. I don't like waiting. What the fuck? What's it going to take for you to answer me? I guess I'm going to have to get-Lay, adhering to the old internet adage, don't feed the trolls. By refusing to reply, Aina hoped Tuilei would grow bored and move on. But they didn't. They continued to message Aina, their tone growing increasingly hostile. You don't have the balls to talk to me. Stop hiding behind your computer screen, you fucking cunt.
“你在吗？我在等。我不喜欢等待。搞什么鬼？你要怎样才肯回答我？我想我得……”伊娜遵循着古老的互联网格言：不要喂养喷子。通过拒绝回复，伊娜希望 Tuilele 会感到无聊并离开。但他们没有。他们继续给伊娜发信息，语气变得越来越敌对。“你没胆量跟我说话。别躲在电脑屏幕后面，你这个该死的婊子。”
Still, Ina wouldn't engage. Then, late the following night of Thursday August 8, over the course of one hour, Ina's email inbox was flooded with more than 50 email and newsletter subscriptions that she had not signed up for. Some were from ideological groups she had no interest in like the Communist Party, the Satanic Temple and Scientology. Others featured disconcerting content relating to bondage, cadavers and animal abuse. Two days later, Ina's husband David received a bizarre and somewhat chilling email. It reported that a preserved, fetal pig had been ordered online and was being sent to
尽管如此，伊娜还是没有理会。随后，在8月8日星期四的深夜，在一小时内，伊娜的电子邮箱被50多封她从未订阅过的电子邮件和通讯订阅淹没了。其中一些来自她毫无兴趣的意识形态团体，如共产党、撒旦圣殿和科学教派。另一些则包含有关捆绑、尸体和虐待动物的令人不安的内容。两天后，伊娜的丈夫戴维收到了一封离奇且令人不寒而栗的电子邮件。邮件称，网上订购了一只保存完好的胎儿猪，正被寄往
the Steiner's home. At around 4pm, a package arrived from Amazon that was addressed to Ina. It contained a Halloween mask depicting a bloody pig face, similar to one worn by the jigsaw killer and his accomplices in the horror film franchise Saw. 15 minutes later, Ina received a notification for the EcommerceBytes Twitter account. It was a new private message from Tuilei that read, Do I have your attention now? Ina did not seek out an explanation for Tuilei's abusive behaviour. It seemed her online harasser knew where she lived and she didn't want to provoke them further. Ina maintained her silence, still hoping it would succeed as a deterrent. But Tuile continued to bombard her with messages like,
斯坦纳家中。下午4点左右，一个来自亚马逊的包裹寄给了伊娜。里面是一个万圣节面具，描绘了一张血淋淋的猪脸，类似于恐怖电影系列《电锯惊魂》（Saw）中竖锯杀手及其同伙所戴的面具。15分钟后，伊娜收到了《电子商务字节》Twitter 账户的通知。那是 Tuilele 发来的新私信，写道：“现在引起你的注意了吗？”伊娜没有寻求对 Tuilele 虐待行为的解释。看来她的网络骚扰者知道她住在哪里，她不想进一步激怒他们。伊娜保持沉默，仍希望这能起到威慑作用。但 Tuilele 继续用信息轰炸她，例如：
You're a fat fuck pussy. David needs to put you in line, cunt. A day later, David Steiner was sent an Amazon package of his own. It contained a book titled, Grief Diaries, Surviving the Loss of a Spouse. Tuilei sent more messages to Ina throughout the day, repeatedly demanding to know what her problem was with eBay. The truth was that Ina didn't have one. Sure, she had written an article about the company's lawsuit with Amazon that could be interpreted as critical, but it was hardly scathing or destructive. And although it wasn't the first time she'd scrutinised eBay's business practices, she afforded them the same degree of respectful critique that she gave every company she wrote
“你这个肥胖的蠢货。戴维需要管教你，婊子。”一天后，戴维·斯坦纳收到了他自己的亚马逊包裹。里面是一本名为《悲伤日记：丧偶后的幸存》（Grief Diaries, Surviving the Loss of a Spouse）的书。Tuilele 整天给伊娜发送更多信息，反复要求知道她对 eBay 有什么问题。事实是伊娜根本没有问题。当然，她写过一篇关于该公司与亚马逊诉讼的文章，可能被解读为批评，但那绝不是尖刻或破坏性的。虽然这不是她第一次审视 eBay 的商业行为，但她给予了他们与她所写的每家公司同等程度的尊重性批评。
about. Earlier that year, she had reported positively on eBay's promise to give sellers greater protection. It was bizarre to think someone would go to such lengths to punish her for holding a rather mild and inconsequential opinion. Ina refused to engage Tuila in any discourse, believing the person behind the username must be unwell. Then on Tuesday August 13, almost a week after Tu Le's harassment began, David Steiner received a voicemail from a representative at Adam and Eve, a US company that sells adult toys online. They were responding to David's purported interest in opening a franchise store. Neither David nor Ina had expressed any interest in such an endeavour.
今年早些时候，她曾积极报道过 eBay 承诺给予卖家更大保护的消息。想到有人会为了惩罚她持有如此温和且无关紧要的观点而采取如此极端的手段，真是不可思议。伊娜拒绝与 Tuilele 进行任何交流，认为用户名背后的人一定是不正常的。随后在8月13日星期二，即 Tuilele 的骚扰开始近一周后，戴维·斯坦纳收到了一份来自 Adam and Eve 的代表的语音留言，这是一家在线销售成人用品的美国公司。他们是在回应戴维据称对开设特许经营店的兴趣。戴维和伊娜都没有表达过对这类事业的任何兴趣。
That same day, Tuilele tweeted e-commerce bites, asking, Are you there? Why won't you answer me? Many families, including mine, make money to pay for food, clothes and rent by selling on eBay. Your stupid idiot comments are pushing buyers away from eBay and hurting families. Stop it now. These messages only served to further confuse Ina and David. At the time, eBay was ranked in the 200s in Fortune 500, an annual list of the 500 largest US industrial corporations as measured by gross income. The company had a market value of over $47 billion and employed 13,000 people worldwide. It was completely unreasonable to think Ina's non-partisan commentary in her niche corner of the internet could impact such an industry powerhouse. Even if it did, shouldn't the contempt be directed at eBay itself? Ina was only reporting the facts. If the business was
同一天，Tuilele 在 Twitter 上向《电子商务字节》提问：“你在吗？为什么不回答我？许多家庭，包括我的，靠在 eBay 上销售来赚取食物、衣服和房租的钱。你那些愚蠢的白痴评论正在把买家从 eBay 推开，伤害了这些家庭。现在就停止。”这些信息只会让伊娜和戴维更加困惑。当时，eBay 在《财富》500强中排名200多位，这是一份按总收入衡量的美国500家最大工业公司的年度榜单。该公司市值超过470亿美元，在全球拥有13,000名员工。认为伊娜在互联网利基角落发表的非党派评论能影响这样一个行业巨头，是完全不合理的。即使真的有影响，难道不应该把蔑视指向 eBay 本身吗？伊娜只是在报道事实。如果业务
faltering, then the solution would be fixing its problems. Silencing Ina might go some way to improving public perception of the company, but it wouldn't resolve the actual issues sellers were facing. Thuy Elay's idiot comments remark was particularly strange, as the Steiners carried themselves like respected journalists. They didn't get involved in frivolous or petty internet drama. The next day, the Steiners received a package from Carolina Biological Supply, a company based in North Carolina that sold science-related products. that sold science-related products. They opened it and were alarmed to discover it contained fly larvae and live spiders. A second package arrived that same day, this one from an insect supply company based in Kansas. It held live cockroaches. Tuilele tweeted the couple,
在衰退，那么解决方案应该是解决其问题。让伊娜闭嘴或许能在一定程度上改善公众对公司的看法，但并不能解决卖家面临的实际问题。Tuilele 的“白痴评论”言论尤其奇怪，因为斯坦纳夫妇表现得像受人尊敬的记者。他们不参与轻浮或琐碎的互联网闹剧。第二天，斯坦纳夫妇收到了一个来自 Carolina Biological Supply 的包裹，这是一家位于北卡罗来纳州、销售科学相关产品的公司。他们打开包裹，惊恐地发现里面装有蝇蛆和活蜘蛛。当天晚些时候，第二个包裹送达，来自堪萨斯州的一家昆虫供应公司。里面装有活蟑螂。Tuilele 在 Twitter 上对这对夫妇说：
cockroaches. 2ELA tweeted the couple, Ina, when you hurt our business, you hurt our families. People will do anything to protect family. Ina and David were rattled. With no idea who was behind the 2ELA account, the couple began increasing their security measures. They installed video cameras outside their home, added some battery-powered alarms, and reported the harassment to the Natick Police Department, which agreed to conduct patrols of the couple's home. The following day, the Steiners were mortified to learn that two of their neighbours had received packages with David's name on them that contained quote, barely legal pornography. Later that day, a florist dropped off an ominous funeral wreath with a card that featured Ina's name.
“伊娜，当你伤害我们的生意时，你就伤害了我们的家庭。人们会不惜一切代价保护家庭。”伊娜和戴维感到惊慌失措。由于不知道 Tuilele 账户背后是谁，这对夫妇开始加强安全措施。他们在屋外安装了摄像机，增加了一些电池供电的警报器，并向纳蒂克警察局报告了骚扰事件，警方同意对这对夫妇的家进行巡逻。第二天，斯坦纳夫妇震惊地得知，他们的两名邻居收到了写有戴维名字的包裹，里面装有“几乎合法的色情制品”。当天晚些时候，一名花商送来了一个不祥的葬礼花圈，卡片上写着伊娜的名字。
This marked the couple's second death-themed delivery. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Here's something every renter needs to hear. Did you know you can actually earn points just by paying rent? Thanks to Build, you can turn your rent payments into rewards for flights, hotel stays, fitness classes and even your next rent payment. Let me explain how it works.
这标志着这对夫妇收到的第二个以死亡为主题的快递。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。这里有每个租房者都需要听到的信息。你知道你实际上可以通过支付房租来赚取积分吗？多亏了 Build，你可以将你的房租支付转化为航班、酒店住宿、健身课程甚至下一次房租支付的奖励。让我解释一下它是如何运作的。
There's no cost to join Build and as a a member you'll earn valuable points on rent and on your everyday spending. BUILT points can be transferred to your favourite hotels and airlines and even the ones you haven't heard of. There are over 500 airlines and 700,000 hotels and properties around the world you can redeem your BUILT points toward. Points can also be redeemed towards a future rent payment and unique experiences that only built members can access. So if you're not earning points on rent,
加入 Build 是免费的，作为会员，你将在房租和日常消费上赚取宝贵的积分。BUILT 积分可以转移到你最喜欢的酒店和航空公司，甚至是那些你没听说过的。全球有超过500家航空公司和700,000家酒店及物业，你可以用 BUILT 积分兑换。积分还可以兑换未来的房租支付以及只有 Build 会员才能享受的独特体验。所以，如果你没有在房租上赚取积分，
my question is, why not? Start earning points on rent you're already paying by going to joinbuilt.com slash casefile. That's j-o-i-n-b-i-l-t dot com slash casefile. Make sure to use our URL so they know we sent you joinbuilt.com slash casefile to start earning points on your rent payments today. A lot has changed over the past year. Casefile has grown its team, introduced new Casefile Presents series and even taken the stage at live events. If you're running a growing e-commerce business, you know how exciting and challenging growth can be. Whether you need more efficiency during the holiday rush or your shipping needs have outgrown your current solutions, ShipStation is here to help. Paulina from the Casefile team uses ShipStation for her Shopify store, and it's completely
我的问题是，为什么不呢？通过访问 joinbuilt.com/casefile，开始在你已经支付的房租上赚取积分。即 j-o-i-n-b-i-l-t 点 com 斜杠 casefile。请务必使用我们的网址，这样他们就知道是我们推荐的。访问 joinbuilt.com/casefile，今天就开始在你的房租支付上赚取积分吧。过去一年发生了很多变化。Casefile 扩大了团队，推出了新的 Casefile Presents 系列，甚至在现场活动中登台亮相。如果你正在经营一家不断增长的电子商务企业，你就知道增长是多么令人兴奋和充满挑战。无论你是在假日高峰期需要更高的效率，还是你的运输需求已经超出了你目前的解决方案，ShipStation 都能为你提供帮助。来自 Casefile 团队的宝琳娜（Paulina）在她的 Shopify 商店中使用 ShipStation，它完全
transformed the way she manages shipping. With everything handled in one simple dashboard, she can track orders, print shipping labels in a single click, and streamline her entire workflow. No more headaches, just efficiency. ShipStation is built to help your business grow. It's the fastest, most affordable way to get products to your customers, with the discounts of up to 89% on UPS, DHL Express and USPS rates. And with seamless integrations for your favourite services and selling channels that you already use, it's never been easier to stay organised.
改变了她管理运输的方式。通过在一个简单的仪表板中处理所有事务，她可以跟踪订单、一键打印运输标签，并简化整个工作流程。不再有头痛，只有效率。ShipStation 旨在帮助你的业务增长。这是将产品送达客户最快、最实惠的方式，UPS、DHL Express 和 USPS 的费率折扣高达89%。通过与你已经使用的最喜欢的服务和销售渠道的无缝集成，保持井井有条从未如此简单。
Ready to take your e-commerce business to the next level? Switch to ShipStation today. Go to shipstation.com and use code CASEFILE to sign up for your free 60 day trial. That's shipstation.com code CASEFILE. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CASEFILE to continue to deliver quality content. Meanwhile, the Steiners had noticed a black Dodge minivan with New York license plates circling their neighborhood. David sensed the vehicle was following him and felt certain he was going to be killed. He took note of the minivan's license plate and reported it to police.
准备好将你的电子商务业务提升到一个新的水平了吗？今天就切换到 ShipStation。访问 shipstation.com 并使用代码 CASEFILE 注册你的免费60天试用。即 shipstation.com 代码 CASEFILE。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CASEFILE 继续提供高质量的内容。与此同时，斯坦纳夫妇注意到一辆挂着纽约车牌的黑色道奇小型货车在他们社区周围盘旋。戴维感觉到这辆车在跟踪他，并确信自己会被杀。他记下了这辆小型货车的车牌并向警方报告。
Officers searched for the vehicle in their databases, but nothing came up that corresponded with the information provided by the Steiners. They nevertheless put out a call on police radio to be on the lookout for the vehicle. It wasn't sighted again. That evening, an emergency plumber was sent to the Steiners' home. At 4.30am the following night, a black car stopped outside their house. A male driver emerged and pulled out a large leather bag which David thought contained a rifle. He shouted to Weiner to call the police, but it was a false alarm. The leather bag contained pizzas, $70 worth ordered on behalf of the Steiners that needed to be paid for.
警察在数据库中搜索了这辆车，但没有发现与斯坦纳夫妇提供的信息相符的任何记录。尽管如此，他们还是在警用无线电上发出了寻找该车辆的呼吁。它再也没有出现过。那天晚上，一名紧急水管工被派往斯坦纳家。第二天凌晨4点30分，一辆黑色轿车停在他们家门外。一名男司机走出来，拿出一个大皮包，戴维以为里面装的是步枪。他大喊让伊娜报警，但这只是虚惊一场。皮包里装的是披萨，价值70美元，是代表斯坦纳夫妇订购的，需要付款。
Shortly before 2pm on Sunday August 18, more than two weeks after the harassment began, the Tui-Lay Twitter account publicly posted Ina Steiners' personal contact details, including her residential address. This act is known as doxing and is a common method of online harassment and intimidation. Three minutes later, Tui-Lay sent Ina a private message asking, You get my gifts, cunt? This explicitly confirmed that the person threatening the Steiners online was the same one sending them unwanted deliveries. However, Tuilei had made a mistake. Doxing was against Twitter's user policy. The platform took down the offending posts and the Tuilei account was suspended, preventing its use for the time being. Yet, Tui-A-Lay's suspension did little to
8月18日星期日，骚扰开始两周多后，下午2点前不久，Tuilele 的 Twitter 账户公开了伊娜·斯坦纳的个人联系方式，包括她的居住地址。这种行为被称为“人肉搜索”（doxing），是网络骚扰和恐吓的常见手段。三分钟后，Tuilele 给伊娜发了一条私信，问道：“收到我的礼物了吗，婊子？”这明确证实了在网上威胁斯坦纳夫妇的人与给他们发送不请自来的快递的人是同一个人。然而，Tuilele 犯了一个错误。人肉搜索违反了 Twitter 的用户政策。该平台删除了违规帖子，Tuilele 账户被暂停，暂时无法使用。然而，Tuilele 的停用并没有多大作用
settle the Steiner's nerves. David now believed he was being followed by a silver or grey Toyota RAV4 GMC. When he went to take pictures of the vehicle with his cell phone, it drove away. David didn't notice it tailing him again. Police took the Steiner's concerns seriously and sent an undercover officer to observe the couple's house from an unmarked jeep with tinted windows. But the officer saw no suspicious activity. activity. The unwanted deliveries continued, including additional pizzas to the Steiner residence and more pornography in David's name to one of their neighbours. On Tuesday August 20, the police were called to the Steiner's home yet again. The couple told them that multiple strangers had shown up at their house in response to an
平息斯坦纳夫妇的紧张情绪。戴维现在认为他被一辆银色或灰色的丰田 RAV4 GMC 跟踪。当他拿出手机拍摄这辆车时，它开走了。戴维没有再注意到它跟踪他。警方认真对待了斯坦纳夫妇的担忧，并派出一名卧底警察从一辆贴有深色车窗的无标志吉普车中观察这对夫妇的房子。但警察没有看到任何可疑活动。不请自来的快递仍在继续，包括给斯坦纳住所的额外披萨，以及更多以戴维名义寄给他们邻居的色情制品。8月20日星期二，警方再次被叫到斯坦纳家。这对夫妇告诉他们，多名陌生人出现在他们家，以响应在 yard sales search.com 上发布的一则为期一周的车库甩卖广告。该列表包含了斯坦纳家的地址，并附有信息：“我们很快就要搬到国外，正试图尽可能多地处理我们的财产。如果我们不在外面，请随意敲门。如果你看到喜欢的东西，也许我们可以达成交易。”这些并不是斯坦纳夫妇收到的唯一不速之客。一篇题为《纳蒂克的街区派对，让我们玩得开心点》的帖子被上传到分类广告网站 Craigslist 上，并附上了他们的地址。“嘿，我们是一些有趣的当地人，在房主下周外出期间为开放参观日接待客人，”帖子声称。
advertisement for a week-long garage sale posted on yard sales search dot com. The listing, which featured the Steiner's home address, included the message, We are moving out of the country soon and are trying to get rid of as many of our possessions as possible. If we are not outside, feel free to knock on the door. Maybe we can make a deal if you see something you like." These weren't the only uninvited guests the Steiners received. A post titled, Block Party in Natick, Let's have some fun, had been uploaded on the classified advertisements website Craigslist, alongside their address. Hey, we are some fun locals hosting guests for an open house while the owners are out of town for the next week, the post claimed.
“随时敲门，按门铃。街区派对将在晚上10点左右开始，但会持续到很晚。单身人士、情侣、换妻者都可以。欢迎大学生。”其他几篇 Craigslist 帖子也鼓励人们访问斯坦纳家。其中一篇将斯坦纳夫妇称为“成熟的专业人士，想在家里找点乐子”，并特别要求“单身人士或其他愿意探索三人行、BDSM 和异装癖的情侣”。8月21日星期三，伊娜·斯坦纳在 Twitter 上收到了一条来自一个名为 AllayTooie 的新账户的评论。该用户名是 Tooie Allay 账户的倒置，伊娜立即
Come knock on the door, ring the doorbell any time of day or night. Block parties will start about 10pm but we'll go late. Singles, couples, swingers, okay. College students are welcome. Several other Craigslist posts also encouraged people to visit the Steiners' home. One referred to the Steiners as, to visit the Steiner's home. One referred to the Steiner's as, mature professionals looking to have some fun at home and asked specifically for, singles or other couples open to exploring threesomes, BDSM and cross-dressing. On Wednesday August 21, Ines Steiner received a comment on Twitter from a new account named AllayTooie. The username was an inversion of the Tooie Allay account, and Ina immediately
怀疑这是同一个人试图绕过他们的 Twitter 停用。当她读到 Alei Tui 的信息时，她的怀疑得到了证实：“别白费力气了，伊娜，你关不掉我。”Alei Tui 给伊娜发送了同样的粗俗和侮辱性的指控，核心是她试图不可挽回地损害 eBay 声誉的错误信念。更糟糕的是，其他匿名 Twitter 用户站出来支持 L.A. Tooey。其中一人写道：“多年的谎言和摧毁家庭。别为此感到自豪，你这个毫无价值的婊子。我也会摧毁你的家庭和生意。看看你喜不喜欢。”同一用户标记了 L.A. Tooey 的账户，问道：“什么时候我们要去纳蒂克拜访她？”
suspected it was the same person trying to bypass their Twitter suspension. Her suspicions were confirmed when she read Alei Tui's message, Nice try Ina, you can't shut me down. Alei Tui sent Ina the same vulgar and insulting accusations, centred around the misguided belief that she was trying to irreparably damage eBay's reputation. Worse still, other anonymous Twitter users came forward to support L.A. Tooey. One wrote, Years of lies and destroying families. Don't be proud of that, you worthless bitch. I will destroy your family and business too. See how you like it. The same user tagged L.A. Tooey's account, asking, and business too. See how you like it."
另一名用户回复道：“我同意。伊娜用所有的负面情绪伤害了小企业，并把买家推向了亚马逊。”第三名用户以一张令人不安的猪头图片作为头像，补充道：“伊娜，专注于别的事情，别再搞我们的客户了。我不想再看到任何关于 eBay 的该死帖子。离我们的生意远点。”这名用户直接写信给 Allay Tooey，问道：“伊娜的地址是多少来着？我想我得去拜访她一下。”
The same user tagged a Leitui's account, asking, "'When are we going to visit her in Nadek?' Another user replied, "'I agree. Ina is hurting small businesses with all the negativity and pushing buyers to Amazon.'" A third user with a disturbing image of a pig's head as their profile picture added, "'Aina, focus on something else and stop fucking with our customers. I don't want to see another fucking post about eBay. Leave our business alone." This sane user wrote to Allay Tooey directly, asking, What's Iner's address again? Guess I have to pay her a visit.
Allay Tooey 回复了斯坦纳家的地址，导致其因人肉搜索而被停用。其他账户都是新的，几乎没有粉丝，写作方式与 Alei Tui 相似，表明它们都是由同一个人运营的。但伊娜无法确定。也有可能他们是其他被 Alei Tui 的闹剧吸引而与之无关的喷子。然而，其中一个账户使用了某位知名 eBay 卖家的名字，这让伊娜怀疑她是否真的招致了该社区的愤怒。
Allay Tooey replied with the Steiner's home address, resulting in a suspension for doxing. The other accounts were new, had few to no followers, and wrote in a similar way to Alei Tui, indicating they were all run by the same person. But Ina couldn't be sure. There was also the possibility that they were other trolls attracted to Alei Tui's drama while being unconnected to it. However, one of the accounts featured the name of a prominent eBay seller, leading Ina to question whether she had in fact drawn the community's ire.
无论如何，伊娜和戴维·斯坦纳受到了如此深刻的恐吓，以至于他们无法休息。两人都饱受压力和焦虑的折磨，并表现出身体症状。他们不敢在公共场合露面，担心自己被跟踪。出于对身份盗窃、欺诈和经济损失的担忧，他们冻结了所有账户。《电子商务字节》来之不易的声誉正在他们眼前被摧毁。斯坦纳夫妇除了躲在家里别无他法。他们取消了无数次与朋友和家人的会面，因为担心他们会暴露自己的
Whatever the case, Ina and David Steiner were so profoundly terrorised they were unable to rest. Both were riddled with stress and anxiety that manifested in physical symptoms. They couldn't go out in public without worrying that they were being followed. Concerned about identity theft, fraud, and financial harm, they froze all their accounts. The hard-earned reputation of e-commerce bites was being destroyed before their eyes. The Steiners could do little else but bunker down at home. They cancelled countless visits with friends and family out of fear they would expose their
亲人受到跟踪活动的威胁。伊娜和戴维决定分房睡，这样如果发生入室抢劫，其中一人受到攻击，另一人可以逃脱并寻求帮助。戴维待在主卧室的前面，在那里他不断观看房产安全摄像头的实时画面。伊娜在后方的一间备用卧室里。这对夫妇在后门设置了一个自制的陷阱，由堆放在洗衣篮上的烤盘组成。如果有人晚上试图从后门闯入，伊娜就会听到。
loved ones to the stalking campaign. Ina and David decided to sleep in separate bedrooms so that if there was a home invasion and one of them was attacked, the other could escape and call for help. David stayed at the front of the house in the main bedroom where he constantly watched a live feed of the property's security cameras. Ina was in a spare bedroom at the rear. The couple had set up a homemade booby trap against the back door consisting of baking trays stacked on top of a laundry card. If anyone tried to break in through the back at night, Ina would hear them.
这对夫妇被对接下来会发生什么的持续恐惧所瘫痪。每次敲门声都让他们感到恐惧，担心杀手终于到来，要落实他们的威胁。与此同时，纳蒂克警察局正在积极调查骚扰事件。他们有一些微弱的线索，其中最重要的一条来自戴维·斯坦纳。他设法拍下了一辆他怀疑正在跟踪他的灰色丰田 RAV4 GMC 的车牌照片。该车辆属于一家名为 Enterprise 的汽车租赁公司。他们的记录显示，在戴维认为自己被该车辆跟踪时，它被租给了一名名叫维罗妮卡·扎伊（Veronica Zay）的女子。这不是调查人员建立的唯一联系
The couple were paralysed by constant fear of what would happen next. They felt a sense of dread with every knock at the door, terrified that a killer had finally arrived to follow through on their threats. Meanwhile, the Natick Police Department was actively investigating the harassment. They had a few tenuous leads, with the most significant coming from David Steiner. He had a few tenuous leads, with the most significant coming from David Steiner. He had managed to snap a photo of the licence plate of a grey-coloured Toyota RAV4 GMC he suspected was following him. The vehicle belonged to a car rental company called Enterprise. Their records showed that at the time David believed he was being stalked by the vehicle, it had been leased to a woman named Veronica Zay. This wasn't the only connection investigators made
与维罗妮卡有关。寄给斯坦纳夫妇的一些物品是使用在加利福尼亚州圣克拉拉市购买的预付借记卡和礼品卡购买的，维罗妮卡居住在那里。商店的闭路电视记录了维罗妮卡购买这些卡的过程。警方发现，维罗妮卡·扎伊最近在波士顿的一家丽思卡尔顿豪华酒店有预订，距离斯坦纳在纳蒂克的家有30分钟车程。斯坦纳夫妇证实他们与维罗妮卡没有任何过往，但奇怪的是，人们发现她在 eBay 工作。维罗妮卡·扎伊于2017年首次受雇于 eBay，当时她23岁。尽管她对技术缺乏兴趣，几乎没用过 eBay 的网站，但维罗妮卡的
to Veronica. Some of the items sent to the Steiners were bought using prepaid debit cards and gift cards purchased in the Californian city of Santa Clara, where Veronica resided. Store CCTV had recorded Veronica buying the cards. Police uncovered that Veronica Zay had a recent booking at a Ritz-Carton luxury hotel in Boston, a 30-minute drive from the Steiner's home in Nadek. a 30 minute drive from the Steiners' home in Nadek. The Steiners confirmed that they had no history with Veronica, but curiously, it was discovered that she worked for eBay. Veronica Zay was first employed by eBay in 2017 when she was 23 years old. Despite her lack of interest in technology and having barely used eBay's website, Veronica's
犯罪学学位使她在位于加利福尼亚州圣何塞的公司总部获得了一个职位。维罗妮卡从情报操作员（一种保安角色）一路晋升为全球安全与弹性部门的情报分析师。这是一个由前警察和安全人员组成的小型、紧密团结的团队，负责防范针对公司的各种规模的威胁。他们调查相关人员，即对 eBay 及其员工构成威胁的个人，并对其进行监控以确保员工安全。这是一项必要的措施，特别是在2018年视频分享网站 YouTube 总部发生枪击事件之后。在那起事件中，多名 YouTube 员工被一名对公司怀有个人
degree in criminology secured her a role at the company's headquarters in San Jose, California. Veronica worked her way up from the role of intelligence operator, a security guard type role, to intelligence analyst in the global security and resiliency division. It was a small, close-knit team consisting mostly of former police and security personnel responsible for staying ahead of small and large-scale threats to the company. They investigated persons of interest, individuals who posed a threat to eBay and its staff, and monitored them to ensure employee safety. It was a necessary measure, especially in the aftermath of a 2018 spree shooting at the headquarters of video sharing website, YouTube. In that incident, multiple YouTube employees were injured by a woman with a personal
怨恨的女子伤害。由于维罗妮卡·扎伊以前从未做过办公室工作，她有些力不从心，依赖于更有经验的员工的专业知识。其中一位是她的直属上司，eBay 安全与安保高级总监詹姆斯·博尔（James Bore）。他是一个坚定、令人生畏的人，希望员工按照他的吩咐去做，不要问问题。有一次，他发现一把刀被留在现场的烧烤架上，便疯狂地用它刺向一把椅子，训斥他的团队说，一个精神错乱的人本可以用这件武器伤害某人。詹姆斯是个电影迷，会召集
vendetta against the company. As Veronica Zay had never worked an office job before, she was somewhat out of her depth and reliant on the expertise of more experienced staff members. One was her immediate supervisor, eBay's Senior director of safety and security, James Bore. He was a firm, intimidating man who wanted employees to do what they were told without asking questions. One time, he found a knife left out on a barbecue grill on site and proceeded to maniacally stab a chair with it, chastising his crew that a deranged individual could have used the weapon to hurt someone. James was a film buff and would summon
员工进入会议室，向他们展示他认为重要的电影片段。在一个片段中，角色被处决以强调观点。另一个涉及拒绝向警方提供信息的犯罪嫌疑人。至少有五次，维罗妮卡被迫观看一部电视剧的片段，其中一位亿万富翁警告下属：“你不需要试图表现得忠诚。你只需要忠诚。”詹姆斯·博尔还喜欢电影《拜见岳父大人》（Meet the Fockers），片中一位退休的中央情报局特工谈到了“信任圈”，这是他对他信任的一小群人的称呼。詹姆斯会在工作场所提到信任圈，当谈到
staff into a boardroom to show them scenes from movies that he deemed significant. In one scene, characters were executed to make a point. Another involved criminal suspects who refused to give information to police. On at least five occasions, Veronica was forced to watch a scene from a television drama in which a billionaire warned a subordinate, "'You don't try to be loyal. You just are." James Boar also liked the film Meet the Fockers, in which a retired CIA agent speaks of a circle of trust, his term for the small group of individuals he trusted. James would reference the circle of trust within the workplace when talking about
他认为其他人不应该知道的事情时。詹姆斯·博尔试图在办公室营造一种类似家庭的环境，并告诉他的团队叫他“爸爸”。对詹姆斯来说，忠诚至关重要，但他是一位不可预测的领导者，无论员工多么忠诚，他都会让他们感到不安。有一次，他让人把员工的个人物品从储物柜里拿出来，扔进垃圾袋，以此教导他们，他们在工作中没有隐私权。维罗妮卡·扎伊是被聘用的合同工，因为她希望有一天能成为全职员工，所以她很谨慎，不做任何可能危及她目标的事情。她所在的办公室人员流动率很高，她刚开始共事的人中，
something he felt no one else should know. James Bore tried to foster a family-like environment in the office and told his team to call him Dad. For James, loyalty was paramount, but he was an unpredictable leader who kept staff on edge no matter their fealty. On one occasion, he had his employees' personal belongings stripped from their lockers and dumped into trash bags in order to teach them that they were not entitled to privacy at work. Veronica Zay was hired as a contract worker, and because she hoped to one day become a full-time employee, she was cautious not to do anything that could jeopardise her goal. There was a high turnover rate in her office and many of the people she started out with,
大多是年长的男性，很快就被年轻的金发女性取代。詹姆斯·博尔会称她们为他的“天使”，以指代虚构的三位女性侦探《霹雳娇娃》（Charlie's Angels），她们以迷人著称。维罗妮卡不喜欢詹姆斯·博尔的行为或办公室里那种邪教般的氛围，但她把蔑视藏在心里。她不想惹麻烦，因为员工会被不可预测地解雇，理由是任何被察觉到的轻率行为。女性员工因为没有对高管微笑、咀嚼钢笔以及在安静的夜班期间自言自语而被解雇。eBay 的高层知道这种功能失调和歧视性的工作文化，但没有解决它。当一家以
mostly older men, were quickly replaced by young blonde haired women. James Boar would call them his angels in reference to the trio of fictional female detectives, Charlie's Angels, who were known for being attractive. Veronica didn't like James Boar's behaviour or the cult-like atmosphere of her office, but she kept her contempt to herself. She had no desire to rock the boat as staff were fired unpredictably and for any perceived indiscretion. Female employees were let go for not smiling at executives, chewing on pens, and singing to themselves during quiet night shifts. eBay's top brass were aware of the dysfunctional and discriminatory work culture, but didn't address it. The situation only worsened when a hedge fund known for being
特别无情而闻名的对冲基金购买了 eBay 的大量股份并开始要求内部变革时，情况变得更糟。从情报分析部门的维罗妮卡·扎伊，一直到 eBay 的首席执行官德文·温尼格，各级人员都感受到了压力。首席执行官得知，在给 eBay 董事会的一封信中，对冲基金暗示要因为公司业绩不佳而撤换他，这让他感到沮丧。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。
particularly ruthless bought a large stake of eBay and began demanding internal changes. The pressure was felt across the board, from Veronica Zay in Intelligence Analytics, all the way up to eBay's Chief Executive Officer, Devin Wannig. The CEO was dismayed to learn that in a letter to eBay's board of directors, the hedge fund alluded to replacing him due to the company's under performance. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。德文·温尼格在电子商务社区中是一个有争议的人物，因为他管理 eBay 的方式。伊娜·斯坦纳在她的在线通讯《电子商务字节》中报道 eBay 的最新商业举措（无论是好是坏）时，经常提到这位首席执行官。正是因为他，她与 eBay 的职业关系随着时间的推移而恶化。在《电子商务字节》的早期，eBay 曾倡导并与该出版物合作。他们邀请伊娜和戴维·斯坦纳采访执行团队成员，
By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Devin Wenneke was a contentious figure in the e-commerce community for the way he oversaw eBay. Ina Steiner often named the CEO when reporting on eBay's latest business moves, good and bad, in her online newsletter, Ecommerce Bytes. And it was because of him that her professional relationship with eBay corroded over time. In the early days of Ecommerce Bytes, eBay advocated for and collaborated with the publication. They invited Ina and David Steiner to interview executive team members,
以及其他员工和承包商。许多 eBay 高管和员工订阅了《电子商务字节》，包括高层管理人员和公共关系人员。但从2012年5月起，首席执行官德文·温尼格开始对斯坦纳夫妇关于 eBay 及其高层的报道提出异议。具体来说，是当他们发表任何突出公司或他本人过错的文章时。伊娜允许读者在她的文章下发表评论，有些人受到网络匿名性的鼓舞，对德文·温尼格特别刻薄。他们称 eBay 为一个腐败的组织，不为卖家提供任何帮助，并给他们增加了过多的费用、过度监管、处罚、销售限制、没完没了的故障和
as well as other employees and contractors. Many eBay executives and employees subscribed to EcommerceBytes, including high-level management and public relations personnel. including high-level management and public relations personnel. But from May 2012 onwards, CEO Devin Wenig started taking issue with the Steiner's reporting on eBay and its upper management. Specifically, when they published anything that highlighted the company's or his faults. Ina allowed readers to leave comments on her articles, and some, emboldened by online anonymity, were particularly vitriolic towards Devin Wenneke. They referred to eBay as a corrupt organisation that offered sellers no help and burdened them with excessive fees, overregulation, penalties, selling limits, never-ending glitches, and
虚假的客户反馈。德文·温尼格被称为笑话、骗子和妄想症患者，一些人断言他几年前就应该被解雇。这导致 eBay 对《电子商务字节》的态度发生了整体转变。他们曾指责该出版物是一个钓鱼网站，这是网络犯罪分子用来诱骗人们泄露个人信息的一种手段。eBay 后来承认这一指控是错误的并撤回了报告。但这一承认并没有缓解紧张局势。对斯坦纳夫妇及其出版物的批评开始出现在他们自己文章的评论区。负责的账户也
false customer feedback. Devin Wenneke was called a joke, a fraud, and delusional, with some asserting that he should have been fired years earlier. This led to an overall attitude shift towards e-commerce bites at eBay. They once accused the publication of being a phishing site, a means used by cyber criminals to trick people into giving up personal information. eBay later admitted this accusation was an error and retracted its report. But the admission didn't ease tensions. Criticisms of the Steiners and their publication began appearing in the comment sections of their own articles. The accounts responsible also
攻击了其他为这对夫妇辩护的合法读者。这些有问题的账户被追踪到与 eBay 相关的 IP 地址。很明显，eBay 员工正在创建虚假的在线身份来攻击斯坦纳夫妇。2019年4月，伊娜写了一篇文章，讲述了德文·温尼格的薪水是其员工平均工资的152倍。德文很恼火，给他的同事、eBay 高级副总裁兼首席通讯官史蒂夫·怀默（Steve Wymer）发了短信，分享了他的沮丧。他们认为伊娜·斯坦纳因为她歪曲故事的方式而故意煽动人们的情绪。
attacked other legitimate readers who came to the couple's defence. The problematic accounts were traced to IP addresses associated with eBay. It was clear eBay employees were creating fake online identities to attack the Steiners. In April 2019, Ina wrote an article about how Devin Wenneg made 152 times the average salary of his employees. Irritated, Devin texted his colleague, eBay's senior vice president and chief of communications officer Steve Wymer, who shared his frustrations. They believed that Ina Steiner was purposefully getting people worked up due to the way she
德文告诉史蒂夫，他们要摧毁她。两人联系了 eBay 的全球安全与弹性部门，特别是团队负责人詹姆斯·博尔。反过来，他通知了维罗妮卡·扎伊和另一位分析师斯蒂芬妮·斯托克韦尔（Stephanie Stockwell）这一情况。这两名女性被指示截图《电子商务字节》的通讯，并实时通过 WhatsApp（一种加密消息应用程序）转发给詹姆斯·博尔，无论白天还是黑夜，一周中的任何一天。这是为了让执行领导层随时了解最新情况。与此同时，德文·温尼格和史蒂夫·怀默聘请了一家咨询公司。
skewed her stories. Devon told Steve that they were going to crush her. The two men reached out to eBay's Global Security and Resiliency Division, specifically to team leader James Bore. In turn, he informed Veronica Zay and another analyst, Stephanie Stockwell, of the situation. The two women were instructed to screenshot eCommerce Bytes newsletters and forward them to James Bore via WhatsApp, an encrypted messaging app, on a real-time basis, day or night, any day of the week. This was to keep executive leadership up to date on an immediate basis. In the meantime, Devin Wenig and Steve Weimer hired a consultant firm.
歪曲了她的报道。德文告诉史蒂夫，他们要彻底击垮她。这两名男子联系了eBay的全球安全与弹性部门，具体联系了团队负责人詹姆斯·博尔。随后，他将情况告知了维罗妮卡·扎伊和另一位分析师斯蒂芬妮·斯托克韦尔。这两名女性接到指示，要求她们实时截取电子商务字节通讯的内容，并随时（无论昼夜或周末）通过加密通讯软件WhatsApp转发给詹姆斯·博尔。此举旨在让高层领导能够即时掌握最新动态。与此同时，德文·温尼格和史蒂夫·韦默聘请了一家咨询公司。
They produced a report titled, Next Steps, Alternative Digital Methods for Reducing Impact of Ina Steiner and David Steiner and E-Commerce Bytes. The report outlined actionable strategies that would drive the Steiner's articles lower in search engine results. One regular commenter on E-Commerce Bytes went by the username FidoMaster. EcommerceBytes went by the username FidoMaster. They were a resident troll known for stirring up drama. FidoMaster posted under various other usernames with their unsuck eBay account named for their biggest gripe. Their dislike of the company spilled beyond the EcommerceBytes comments section onto Twitter, where they harassed the business
他们制作了一份名为《下一步：减少Ina Steiner、David Steiner和E-Commerce Bytes影响的替代数字方法》的报告。报告概述了旨在降低Steiner夫妇文章在搜索引擎结果中排名的可行策略。E-Commerce Bytes的一位常客使用用户名FidoMaster。他们是一个以挑起事端而闻名的网络喷子。FidoMaster使用各种其他用户名发帖，其“unsuck eBay”账户名源于他们最大的不满。他们对该公司的厌恶从EcommerceBytes评论区蔓延到了Twitter，并在那里骚扰该企业。
directly. Sometimes, FidoMaster impersonated official eBay communications by using a distorted version of the company's logo. They also provided parody answers to customer questions directed at eBay's official Twitter account. In an Ecommerce Bytes article posted in May 2019, Ines Steiner wrote about how eBay had built an expensive replica of a popular Manhattan bar called Walkers at their headquarters in California. Quote,
直接骚扰。有时，FidoMaster会通过使用公司Logo的扭曲版本来冒充eBay的官方通讯。他们还针对eBay官方Twitter账户上的客户提问提供恶搞回答。在2019年5月发布的一篇Ecommerce Bytes文章中，Ina Steiner写道，eBay如何在加州总部建造了一个名为Walkers的流行曼哈顿酒吧的昂贵复制品。引用如下：
It's probably news to sellers and shareholders that eBay has a pub-like lounge on campus, especially one built with what appears to be no expenses spared. This news drew the ire of Fido Master, who tweeted a link to the article with a message calling the bar a self-indulgent vanity project that was a throwback to Internet and gaming company CEOs lavish over spending on legacy facilities and landmarks. Fido Master called out CEO Devin Wenig by name, criticising him for undertaking the project while eBay was experiencing cost reduction, layoffs and scrutiny by activist investors. Even though Fido Master's tweets about eBay only amassed a dozen or so likes, the company's
“对于卖家和股东来说，eBay在园区内拥有一个类似酒吧的休息室，这大概是个新闻，尤其是这个休息室看起来是不惜工本建造的。”这一消息激怒了FidoMaster，他在推特上转发了这篇文章，并附上一条信息，称该酒吧是一个自我放纵的虚荣项目，是互联网和游戏公司CEO在遗留设施和地标上大肆挥霍的倒退。FidoMaster点名批评了CEO Devin Wenig，指责他在eBay经历成本削减、裁员并受到激进投资者审查时开展该项目。尽管FidoMaster关于eBay的推文只有十几个人点赞，但该公司的
security division kept a large file on the unknown identity. James Boar and two other senior members of the security division named Brian Gilbert and David Harville suspected that Fido Master was either in cahoots with the Steiners or a sock puppet account, a false online identity used for deceptive purposes. They figured if Fido Master was a sock puppet, then Iona and David Steiner were behind it. behind it. Devin Wenig and Steve Wymer were fed up. In one email, Steve claimed that the Steiner's website gave him ulcers, harmed employee morale, and trickled into everything about their brand. He wrote, "...I genuinely believe these people are acting out of malice and someone chose to let this slide. It has grown to a point that is absolutely unacceptable. It's the blind eye toward
安全部门却保留了一份关于这个未知身份的大量档案。James Baugh和安全部门的其他两名高级成员Brian Gilbert和David Harville怀疑FidoMaster要么是与Steiner夫妇勾结，要么是一个“马甲”账户，即用于欺骗目的的虚假在线身份。他们认为如果FidoMaster是马甲，那么Ina和David Steiner就是幕后黑手。Devin Wenig和Steve Wymer受够了。在一封电子邮件中，Steve声称Steiner夫妇的网站让他得了溃疡，损害了员工士气，并渗透到他们品牌的方方面面。他写道：“……我真诚地相信这些人是出于恶意，而有人选择了放任自流。它已经发展到绝对不可接受的地步。这是对
graffiti that turns into mayhem syndrome, and I'm sick about it." Steve, as well as Devin, wanted the Steiner's silenced. The men granted the security division carte blanche to take down the Steiners. Whatever it takes, Steve Weimer asserted in an email. He promised to manage any bad fallout and made it clear that the security team would receive support and backing from the executive leadership at eBay, regardless of the volatility or force used against the Steiners. They didn't care that Ina was merely exercising her First Amendment right to report on eBay, as she had done for years without issue. At no point did she fabricate information about the company, attack them unfairly,
涂鸦演变成骚乱综合症的视而不见，我对此感到恶心。”Steve和Devin都想让Steiner夫妇闭嘴。这些人授予安全部门全权去对付Steiner夫妇。Steve Wymer在一封电子邮件中声称：“不惜一切代价。”他承诺处理任何负面后果，并明确表示安全团队将得到eBay高层领导的支持和背书，无论对Steiner夫妇使用何种波动性手段或武力。他们不在乎Ina只是在行使她的第一修正案权利来报道eBay，正如她多年来一直所做的那样，从未出现过问题。她从未捏造过关于公司的信息，也没有不公平地攻击他们，
or discourage her readers from using their services. Her publication was highly regarded within the e-commerce community for providing balanced reporting. Ina herself had gained considerable goodwill and recognition for her vast knowledge and was a widely cited authority on marketplace selling. Still, for her critics at eBay, taking down Ina would send a message to all journalists that negative reporting of their company would not be tolerated. On Saturday June 8 2019, senior eBay Security Division team member Brian Gilbert flew across the country to Boston.
或阻止她的读者使用他们的服务。她的出版物因提供平衡的报道而在电子商务社区中备受推崇。Ina本人因其渊博的知识而获得了相当多的善意和认可，是市场销售领域被广泛引用的权威。然而，对于她在eBay的批评者来说，打倒Ina将向所有记者传达一个信息：对他们公司的负面报道是不可容忍的。2019年6月8日星期六，eBay安全部门高级团队成员Brian Gilbert飞往波士顿。
He then drove to the Steiner's home in Natick and scrawled the word Fido-Master on the couple's front fence to no effect. Then, acting at the direction of Senior Director of Safety and Security James Boar, Brian began reconnaissance into the Steiner's lives. He attended a yard sale at the couple's home, falsely posing as a potential buyer to gain intelligence. He then returned to Wee Bay headquarters in California to help devise a plan to stop the Steiners once and for all. The security team's plan was dubbed the White Knight Strategy, a white knight being a term for someone who comes to another's aid. Basically, they would secretly harass the Steiners until the couple feared for their lives.
然后他开车前往Steiner夫妇在Natick的家中，在夫妇俩的前院围栏上潦草地写下“Fido-Master”字样，但没有效果。随后，在安全与安保高级总监James Baugh的指示下，Brian开始对Steiner夫妇的生活进行侦察。他参加了这对夫妇家中的庭院旧货出售，伪装成潜在买家以获取情报。随后，他回到加州的eBay总部，帮助制定了一个彻底阻止Steiner夫妇的计划。安全团队的计划被称为“白骑士策略”，“白骑士”是指帮助他人的人。基本上，他们会秘密骚扰Steiner夫妇，直到这对夫妇担心自己的生命安全。
Then they would offer eBay's assistance to help stop the attacks. They believed this would win the Steiners favour and to deter them from covering eBay unfavourably in the future. It all began on Thursday August 1 2019, after Ina Steiner posted her article on eBay's lawsuit against Amazon. In it, she mentioned comments made by CEO Devin Wenneke, adding that he seemingly lacked appreciation for sellers' desire to diversify selling channels. The comments section was flooded with messages critical of eBay. One commenter asked, how about instead of trying to sue Amazon you just make eBay a better place for sellers? After seeing the feedback from the article, eBay VP Steve Wymer texted security head James Boar,
然后他们会提出eBay的协助，以帮助停止这些攻击。他们认为这将赢得Steiner夫妇的好感，并阻止他们未来对eBay进行负面报道。这一切始于2019年8月1日星期四，在Ina Steiner发布了关于eBay起诉亚马逊的文章之后。在文章中，她提到了CEO Devin Wenig发表的评论，并补充说他似乎缺乏对卖家希望实现销售渠道多元化的愿望的理解。评论区充斥着批评eBay的信息。一位评论者问道：“与其试图起诉亚马逊，为什么不把eBay变成一个对卖家更好的地方呢？”在看到文章的反馈后，eBay副总裁Steve Wymer给安全主管James Baugh发了短信，
saying, I know he's out with a hot piece on the litigation. If we are ever going to take her down, now is the time. Hatred is a sin. I am very sinful. I want her done. I know is a biased troll who needs to get burned down. I want to see ashes, as long as it takes, whatever it takes." James Boar and his team of six, including Brian Gilbert, David Harville, Stephanie Stockwell, Veronica Zay, and two other Rebay security analysts named Philip Cook and Stephanie Popp launched a series of ploys they had brainstormed together. Their aim was to intimidate, threaten, torture, terrorise and ultimately silence the Steiners. They created the Twitter account TuiLA and later
说：“我知道她刚发了一篇关于诉讼的热门文章。如果我们打算打倒她，现在就是时候了。仇恨是一种罪。我非常有罪。我想让她完蛋。我知道她是一个需要被烧毁的偏见喷子。我想看到灰烬，无论需要多久，不惜一切代价。”James Baugh和他的六人团队，包括Brian Gilbert、David Harville、Stephanie Stockwell、Veronica Zea，以及另外两名名为Philip Cook和Stephanie Popp的eBay安全分析师，发起了一系列他们共同策划的策略。他们的目的是恐吓、威胁、折磨、恐怖化并最终让Steiner夫妇闭嘴。他们创建了Twitter账户TuiLA，后来又创建了
Alei Tui and other supportive sock puppet accounts to bombard the couple around the clock with frightening online messages. They mailed them disturbing packages and sent strangers to their house at all hours. Some travelled to Boston to stalk the couple in rented vehicles. They monitored Natick Police's radio communications and when they heard messages about the car they were in, they returned it and rented a new one. One time, they paused their surveillance upon noticing an undercover officer in an unmarked jeep was keeping an eye on the couple's home. Another time, the Steiners reported the license plate details of a Dodge minivan the group were in, but the couple were off by one letter, preventing a positive ID. The eBay group plotted to
Alei Tui和其他支持性的马甲账户，全天候用可怕的在线信息轰炸这对夫妇。他们给他们寄送了令人不安的包裹，并随时派陌生人到他们家。一些人前往波士顿，驾驶租赁车辆跟踪这对夫妇。他们监控Natick警方的无线电通讯，当听到关于他们所驾驶车辆的信息时，他们就退还车辆并租用新的。有一次，当注意到一辆未标记吉普车里的便衣警察正在监视这对夫妇的家时，他们暂停了监视。另一次，Steiner夫妇报告了该团伙所乘道奇小型货车的车牌详情，但这对夫妇少记了一个字母，导致无法进行正面识别。eBay团伙密谋
put a tracking device on the Steiners car and even practiced doing so, but were thwarted by the couple parking in their garage. David Harville purchased tools and rubber gloves so he could break into the Steiner's garage, but the plan ultimately fell through. The group had other ideas that didn't come to fruition, including ordering the Steiner's an exotic dancer and sending a coffin to their home. They covered their tracks by registering for a software development conference in Boston that they never intended to attend, giving them a reason to be in the area. The team also used encrypted messaging apps and email accounts, laptops with undetectable IP addresses, burner phones
在Steiner夫妇的车上安装追踪装置，甚至进行了练习，但因这对夫妇将车停在车库里而受阻。David Harville购买了工具和橡胶手套，以便闯入Steiner夫妇的车库，但计划最终落空。该团伙还有其他未能实现的点子，包括为Steiner夫妇订购异国舞者并向他们家中寄送棺材。他们通过注册一个他们从未打算参加的波士顿软件开发会议来掩盖行踪，这给了他们出现在该地区的理由。该团队还使用了加密通讯应用和电子邮件账户、IP地址无法检测的笔记本电脑、一次性手机
and prepaid debit cards. They also created a dossier on the Steiners, falsely accusing them of being persons of interest for threats they made against eBay and its executive management. The document was to be given to police if the group was compromised, to discredit the Steiners and make them appear dangerous, thus defaming their reputations and credibility. After Natick police identified Veronica Zay and discovered her connection to eBay, they sought to interview her. But when they called Veronica's cell phone, James Bore answered. when they called Veronica's cell phone, James Bore answered. He lied, telling police that he was Veronica's husband and that all questions for her could be directed to him. Following the call, James drove Veronica to the airport to flee Massachusetts.
和预付借记卡。他们还建立了一份关于Steiner夫妇的档案，虚假指控他们是针对eBay及其高管的威胁的嫌疑人。如果该团伙被曝光，这份文件将被交给警方，以抹黑Steiner夫妇并使他们看起来很危险，从而诋毁他们的声誉和可信度。在Natick警方确认了Veronica Zea并发现了她与eBay的联系后，他们试图采访她。但当他们拨打Veronica的手机时，James Baugh接听了。他撒谎告诉警方他是Veronica的丈夫，所有针对她的问题都可以直接问他。通话结束后，James开车送Veronica去机场逃离马萨诸塞州。
Police then reached out to eBay directly via an email account that happened to be overseen by Brian Gilbert, one of the conspirators. Brian travelled to Natick to speak with authorities in person, telling them that eBay had no involvement in the intimidation or threats perpetrated against the Steiners. He even brazenly offered eBay's assistance to investigate the matter. However, the conspirators were starting to suspect that the jig was up. They reconvened in a conference room at eBay's headquarters to discuss their next steps. James Bore ordered his team not to talk to anyone and to keep the names of CEO Devin Wenig and senior VP Steve Wymer out of all conversations. Whenever police called any of the staff members
警方随后通过一个恰好由共谋者之一Brian Gilbert监管的电子邮件账户直接联系了eBay。Brian前往Natick亲自与当局交谈，告诉他们eBay没有参与针对Steiner夫妇的恐吓或威胁。他甚至厚颜无耻地提出eBay愿意协助调查此事。然而，共谋者们开始怀疑事情败露了。他们在eBay总部的一间会议室重新集结，讨论下一步行动。James Baugh命令他的团队不要与任何人交谈，并将CEO Devin Wenig和高级副总裁Steve Wymer的名字排除在所有对话之外。每当警方致电任何员工
for further inquiries, the conversation was put on loudspeaker so everyone could listen in and maintain a consistent story. Stephanie Pop posted five new tweets from one of the accounts used to harass the Steiners to give the illusion that the perpetrators were still at large. It didn't work. The entire plot was gradually exposed by Natick detectives. was gradually exposed by Natick detectives. eBay terminated the seven employees involved, all of whom were charged with various conspiracy offences pertaining to cyberstalking, witness tampering, and stalking. Some also faced charges for the attempted cover-up and obstruction of the criminal investigation. The charges carried a sentence of up to five years in prison, three years of supervised release, a fine of up to $250,000, and restitution.
进行进一步询问时，对话都会被调至扬声器模式，以便每个人都能听到并保持口径一致。Stephanie Popp从用于骚扰Steiner夫妇的账户之一发布了五条新推文，以制造肇事者仍然逍遥法外的假象。但这没用。整个阴谋逐渐被Natick侦探揭露。eBay解雇了涉案的七名员工，他们都被控犯有与网络跟踪、干扰证人及跟踪相关的各种共谋罪。一些人还面临掩盖罪行和妨碍刑事调查的指控。这些指控最高可判处五年监禁、三年监督释放、最高25万美元罚款以及赔偿金。
All seven of the conspirators ultimately pleaded guilty and provided full admissions. Their confessions, along with a forensic examination of their communication devices, provided a detailed picture of their crimes. They received varying sentences, including probation, community service, fines, and upwards of 57 months' prison time. James Boar, the ringleader who received the harshest sentence, turned to the Steiners during his hearing and said, I was 100% responsible for everything that happened on my watch. For that, I am truly sorry.
所有七名共谋者最终都认罪并提供了全面供述。他们的供词，连同对其通讯设备的法医检查，提供了他们犯罪的详细图景。他们受到了不同的判决，包括缓刑、社区服务、罚款以及长达57个月的监禁。作为主谋并受到最严厉判决的James Baugh在听证会上转向Steiner夫妇说：“我对在我监督下发生的一切负100%的责任。对此，我深表歉意。”
eBay permitted CEO Devin Wenneke to resign with a $57 million severance package. Senior Vice President Steve Wymer was terminated with an undisclosed severance package. Both men denied any direct involvement in the harassment of the Steiners and maintained they had done nothing wrong. In a statement, Steve Weimer insisted, There was no direction, no knowledge, no private understanding, no tacit approval, ever. I was just speaking off the cuff. Devin Wenig made similar remarks in his own statement. A law firm hired by eBay to investigate the harassment concluded that neither Devin Wenneg or Steve Wymer directed or knew that criminal acts would follow their
eBay允许CEO Devin Wenig辞职，并给予5700万美元的遣散费。高级副总裁Steve Wymer被解雇，并获得了未公开金额的遣散费。两人都否认直接参与了对Steiner夫妇的骚扰，并坚称自己没有做错任何事。在一份声明中，Steve Wymer坚称：“从来没有任何指示、没有知情、没有私下谅解、没有默许。我只是随口说说。”Devin Wenig在自己的声明中也发表了类似的言论。一家被eBay聘请来调查骚扰事件的律师事务所得出结论，Devin Wenig或Steve Wymer都没有指示或知道犯罪行为会随之而来。
orders. An internal investigation deemed the man's messages inappropriate, but it too asserted there was no evidence the pair had authorized or had prior knowledge of the acts directed towards the Steiners. Both men easily slotted into leadership positions at other companies with no concerns expressed about their history at eBay. According to federal prosecutors, the evidence uncovered during the police investigation was insufficient to charge either man with any crimes. In an exclusive interview with the New York Times, Veronica Zay revealed that her participation in the scheme had a long-lasting impact on her life. When her new employer found out about it,
他们的命令。内部调查认为这些人的信息不恰当，但也断言没有证据表明两人授权或预先知道针对Steiner夫妇的行为。两人都轻松地在其他公司获得了领导职位，没有人对他们在eBay的历史表示担忧。据联邦检察官称，警方调查期间发现的证据不足以对两人中的任何一人提出刑事指控。在接受《纽约时报》的独家采访时，Veronica Zea透露，她参与该计划对她的生活产生了持久的影响。当她的新雇主发现这件事时，
Veronica was immediately fired. She struggled to find another job and had to move back in with her parents. She said that she hadn't enjoyed harassing the Steinitz and she'd often call her mother in tears about her own actions. Despite this, the pressure, manipulation, and toxic environment at eBay compelled her to continue doing something that she knew was wrong. Quote, It's easy to say why didn't I leave, but in the moment I was terrified and stuck. I am so sorry. I regret playing even a small role here. If I could go back in time and prevent the Steiners from experiencing this in any way, I would do so in a heartbeat. I don't know when I'll ever trust an employer again, or when an employer will ever trust me."
Veronica立即被解雇了。她努力寻找另一份工作，不得不搬回父母家住。她说她并不喜欢骚扰Steiner夫妇，经常会哭着给母亲打电话讲述自己的行为。尽管如此，eBay的压力、操纵和有毒环境迫使她继续做她明知是错误的事情。引用如下：“很容易说为什么我不离开，但在那一刻，我感到恐惧并被困住了。我非常抱歉。我后悔在这里扮演了哪怕是一个小角色。如果我能回到过去，以任何方式阻止Steiner夫妇经历这一切，我会毫不犹豫地这样做。我不知道我什么时候才能再次信任雇主，或者雇主什么时候会再次信任我。”
The New York Times also tracked down the person behind the online account FidoMaster, whose trolling had led, in part, to the Steiners' ordeal. Some of the offenders had thought the Steiners themselves were behind the account, despite there being no evidence to support this. It turned out that Fido Master wasn't connected to the couple in any way. His wife was an eBay seller and he just wanted to vent online about the issues he had with the company. He clarified that he had never conspired with the Steiners to damage eBay's reputation. As a direct result of their former employees' actions, eBay had to pay a $3 million dollar fine. They have also since apologised to the Steiners and according
《纽约时报》还追踪到了在线账户FidoMaster背后的那个人，他的喷子行为在一定程度上导致了Steiner夫妇的磨难。一些犯罪者曾认为Steiner夫妇本人是该账户的幕后黑手，尽管没有任何证据支持这一点。事实证明，FidoMaster与这对夫妇没有任何联系。他的妻子是eBay卖家，他只是想在网上发泄他对公司的不满。他澄清说，他从未与Steiner夫妇合谋损害eBay的声誉。作为其前员工行为的直接结果，eBay不得不支付300万美元的罚款。他们此后也向Steiner夫妇道歉，并且根据
to their new CEO, Jamie Iannone, the company has... strengthened its policies, procedures, controls and training, while remaining committed to upholding high standards of conduct and ethics. In 2021, the Steiners filed a lawsuit against eBay, the seven defendants in the criminal case and several other relevant parties, including Devin Wenneg and Steve Wymer. Although the two former eBay VIPs had denied involvement in or knowledge of the crimes committed against the Steiners, the couple suspected this wasn't entirely true. Forensic copies of Steve Wymer's personal and company cell phones showed that communications from August 2019 were missing,
他们的新任CEO Jamie Iannone的说法，公司已经……加强了其政策、程序、控制和培训，同时继续致力于维护高标准的行为和道德准则。2021年，Steiner夫妇对eBay、刑事案件中的七名被告以及包括Devin Wenig和Steve Wymer在内的其他几个相关方提起了诉讼。尽管这两位前eBay高管否认参与或知晓针对Steiner夫妇的犯罪行为，但这对夫妇怀疑这并非完全属实。Steve Wymer个人和公司手机的法医副本显示，2019年8月的通讯记录丢失了，
leading authorities to believe they were deleted. However, records recovered from other participants' devices showed that multiple text messages and emails were sent to Steve Weimer informing him about some of their activities. When one conspirator emailed Steve to tell him the police were investigating eBay, Steve replied, "...Please do not do anything until I can check a few things. I don't want us to engage." The Steiners believed that Steve Weimer at least should have been indicted for obstructing justice, destroying evidence and misleading an investigation. Their attorney stated, "...I think the federal government is taking the position that they didn't have enough evidence to indict Weimer and other executives. Our position is that you
导致当局认为它们被删除了。然而，从其他参与者设备中恢复的记录显示，多条短信和电子邮件被发送给Steve Wymer，告知他他们的一些活动。当一名共谋者发邮件告诉Steve警方正在调查eBay时，Steve回复道：“……请不要做任何事情，直到我能核实一些事情。我不希望我们参与其中。”Steiner夫妇认为，至少应该起诉Steve Wymer妨碍司法公正、销毁证据和误导调查。他们的律师表示：“……我认为联邦政府的立场是，他们没有足够的证据起诉Wymer和其他高管。我们的立场是，你
can't find the evidence you're not looking for. They just weren't looking. The civil proceedings are still underway as of June 2024. As a result of the harassment, Ina and David suffered permanent psychological trauma and significant economic damage. Despite this, the Steiners continue to publish e-commerce bites and still report on news pertaining to eBay. While they never made any public statements in the aftermath of the harassment, Ina wrote a number of articles on the case, maintaining her trademark fact-based and unbiased reporting, with no personal opinions provided. I can hear the explosions. I didn't know what was happening. I'm Vicki Petratus.
找不到你没在寻找的证据。他们只是没在找。截至2024年6月，民事诉讼仍在进行中。由于骚扰，Ina和David遭受了永久性的心理创伤和重大的经济损失。尽管如此，Steiner夫妇继续出版E-Commerce Bytes，并继续报道与eBay相关的新闻。虽然他们在骚扰事件发生后从未发表过任何公开声明，但Ina撰写了多篇关于此案的文章，保持了她标志性的基于事实和公正的报道，没有提供任何个人观点。我能听到爆炸声。我不知道发生了什么。我是Vicki Petratus。
And I'm Emily Webb. We are true crime authors and podcasters with a long history of interviewing people who've experienced unthinkable events. The next guy had this Molotov cocktail in his hand and I just saw him lighting it. Are you listening? Pay attention. We're at Link Cafe. A gentleman has taken us hostage. He's got a gun and he's got a bomb. He turned towards me and he had this demonic look on his face and just came at me. These stories will have you on the edge of your seats.
我是Emily Webb。我们是真实犯罪作家和播客主持人，有着采访经历过不可思议事件的人的悠久历史。“下一个人手里拿着这个莫洛托夫鸡尾酒瓶，我看到他点燃了它。”你在听吗？注意了。我们在Link Cafe。一位绅士劫持了我们。他有枪，还有炸弹。“他转向我，脸上带着恶魔般的表情，直接朝我冲过来。”这些故事会让你坐立难安。
My shield man wasn't there anymore. It was me by myself. I had no protection. We are going to die now. Who could get out of that situation? I could hear the explosions. I didn't know what was happening. It's just a matter of self-preservation to get myself out of there. We get to ask questions that most would never ask. And because of that, we get told things most would never hear about. And I couldn't get my gun out. I'm sort of fighting with him. He's stabbing me.
“我的盾牌手不在了。是我一个人。我没有任何保护。我们现在要死了。”谁能从那种情况下逃脱？我能听到爆炸声。我不知道发生了什么。这只是为了自保而让自己逃离那里。我们有机会问大多数人永远不会问的问题。正因为如此，我们被告知了大多数人永远不会听到的事情。“我无法拔出我的枪。我正在和他搏斗。他在刺我。”
Maybe he just hit his head on the ground when he went down. Maybe he's okay. I saw that she wasn't in a very good way. Yeah, this will be difficult for me to talk about. What draws us to these stories is the strength of the people coming out the other side of what they've been through. But it was eight years before I processed what happened in the siege.
也许他倒下时只是头撞到了地上。也许他没事。“我看到她的情况不太好。”是的，谈论这件事对我来说会很困难。吸引我们关注这些故事的是那些经历过这一切后走出来的人们的坚强。“但在我处理完围攻中发生的事情之前，已经过去了八年。”
There is a way. It's not going to be easy. You might have pitfalls, but you've got to keep going. I'm not going to let it beat me or define me. So even though these are stories of the unthinkable, they are also stories of hope. You've got to be the best for you first before you can be the best for someone else. The Unthinkable is available now. Be sure to download and follow The Unthinkable
有一种方法。这不会很容易。你可能会遇到陷阱，但你必须继续前进。我不会让它打败我或定义我。所以，尽管这些是不可思议的故事，但它们也是希望的故事。“在你能成为别人的最好之前，你必须先成为最好的自己。”《不可思议》现已上线。请务必下载并关注《不可思议》
wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论你在哪里收听播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。